I haven't seen you in a while they've
been traveling constantly I went on in
the best vacation of my life I've never
had six weeks off like as a professional
I mean my twenties were like ten years
off but I didn't really go anywhere
important you know I was a waitress and
I didn't I couldn't afford to go
anywhere this time I ended my show and
the day after I just got as far away
from America as possible I went to Spain
we drove through Spain the south of
Spain I went to China you would love it
in China cuz you would be like a big
deal there really yeah why would I be a
big deal in China you'd be like the most
masculine man there I mean have you seen
the Chinese men ever I am I've never
been to China very very small okay so
you're saying I'd be taller than
everybody you would be like Hercules
over there so you're saying I'd be yeah
I'd be like a god it must be a your
muscular tall your look at your skin
tone
I'm not sure where you're going with
that I'm just saying for them if they
saw you coming they would be like oh my
god what is that yeah I get plenty of
that here in America China for what the
hell is that true story when I was a
little kid my dad went on a business
trip and he took me with him and I had
bright orange hair and freckles and two
dead front teeth and they were my mom
before I went put me in a multicolored
Madras jacket and I went with my dad
with bangs and everywhere I went people
were like oh and touching me like I was
a freak yeah and it was the most where'd
you go I went all I went through all
through South America all around South
America everybody had never seen I was
like my dad was walking around with a
monkey dressed in his suit and everybody
was going up to me it was horrifying is
really very funny yeah terrible for a
child but I would like to see something
like that happening life give me a lot
of I'm glad my pain brought you some
pleasure now you're planning a trip to
the Amazon is that right I am cuz I'm
really scared I mean I don't know what
I'm gonna have time off like this again
because I have kind of you know this is
like a few months here and there so I'm
going to South America and then I'm
gonna go to the Amazon because I'm
really scared of snakes and I want to
kind of just like go and have somebody
have a protector there I've hired a man
to handle me and to take me around
really like literally because I will
have like I will freak out but I need a
person that has been around snakes that
is know I said no like I don't want a 20
year old somebody who's like oh I'm
gonna go work in the Amazon for you know
a summer and then try and protect me
from an anaconda
I want a 45 year old dark hair bearded
man who is very muscular and that can
has dealt with women like me before
right so you all want to go to the place
where because the thing you say you fear
the most is snakes and you want to go to
the place that has the scariest snake
yeah because I think it's important to
be brave no I completely I completely
disagree I think there are certain
things that are you're supposed to be
afraid of there's a reason that you're
afraid of an anaconda you don't want to
get near it I wouldn't go well then
you're a little [ __ ] that's
[Applause]
yes I'm a little [ __ ] yes
say yes to that - I'm the little [ __ ]
that doesn't want to fight the Anaconda
well you can stay in your small little
world but I want to go out I want to see
I went diving with sharks would you ever
do that I just went to French Polynesia
and went scuba dive with sharks now it
was crazy were you in it like a pro if
there was a steel cage around me no I
had another man who was protecting me
there tell you much you sounds like man
you found some further adventure escorts
turning down you're with a gigolo
I'm kind of scared of Thai restaurants
but I got this handsome guy
he's really handsome with piercing blue
eyes beer and mussels I've got a really
brave Thai man to take me to my
restaurant yeah no yeah I you there's
something for everybody you can hire
somebody to help you do anything and I
will do that I have no shame in that I
got there on my own I'm not responsible
so you're gonna go you're gonna explore
the Anaconda where you touch an anaconda
well I don't know I don't know if I
could touch one I don't know if you can
go up and handle the snakes and the
trees like I don't think that's go thats
happening down there it's not a zoo I
would I'm just saying if you're going
all the way there you my parrot of zoos
yes a little bit are you afraid of a zoo
you don't know yeah I mean I don't know
I don't know what you're afraid of it
sounds like you're pretty scared uh I'm
very frightened all the time okay though
mostly celebrities coming out I'm a
celebrity I'm scared of celeb reason I
chose this
you